like so so going okay so going back to
the next next topic tonight okay we're
going to talk about women getting
pregnant first going okay so i i'm going
to give you my opinion and you can
comment on it i think
it's 99.999
the woman's fault if she gets pregnant
why do you think that because we are in
control of sex
we
one there's a million forms of birth
control
two you can you can
you get to pick who you sleep with yep
and three
there's condoms and four you can even
get an abortion
so i think if you get pregnant it's your
own fault so you said it's 99.9 women's
i think that men out here just shooting
up and random girls are dumb okay i
think you guys are stupid
so do you think so but but i would say
that the responsibility is mostly on the
woman rather than the guy
so i
i
don't disagree
that culturally so
there is more power in the woman in
regards to getting pregnant
but to say that men are only responsible
for one percent of that i disagree
i would say
because it does take two to tango
because here's the thing right
it is true that most men would have sex
with anything yeah
but there are the small percentage of
men who maybe have a lot of options
wouldn't
they exercise
discipline especially if their time is
money right but even even if let's say
they were a condom right what happened
to drake
how does it count it does count that
happens to really successful men all the
time oh no what i mean is like that's
not that's completely on her that's not
even one person but that's what i'm
saying like even if a guy wears a condom
a girl can take it it's true that's
that's true that like that's an
exception that's that's not his fault
but i would i would say if she got
pregnant from that that's that's not 99
her that's 100 her yeah that's none of
him yeah i'm saying if it was
[ __ ] you drake
no but if um if a guy if a guy has
because if she chooses to have
unprotected sex with him yeah she's
making that choice but he's making okay
but let's say she does who is the who is
the choice to take the plan b pill
who has honor who has the power to yeah
she does she that's why who is who has
the power to get an abortion it is her
yeah it's true does the men have any say
in that i agree so that's why i say it's
it's her own fault you could you could
okay let's say let's say
one you can track your cycle there's
only like five days
in a month or whatever that you're
really likely to get pregnant i know it
can happen outside of that yeah okay but
you can track your cycle
that doesn't work what can you do a
condom okay
if that doesn't work you can get a plan
b pill if that doesn't work next time
around get an iud so if that doesn't
work no no i'm not done okay if that
doesn't work and you get pregnant you
can go get an abortion
the men have no say in this none i know
so so like that's what i said culturally
so i don't understand how these girls
are saying oh it just happened what do
you mean it just happened that i agree
that's silly like any girls just like oh
my gosh it just happens you got pregnant
like
you you played that part yeah here's my
question to you right so there's like
over 40 forms of birth control for women
yeah
if it were reversed there was over 40
forms of birth control for men yeah but
it was still obviously women who choose
who have sex with so i'm saying the
intersexual dynamics yeah yeah yeah but
in terms of culturally it is men who has
the birth control power not women
would that then change your position
with that who's responsible
and who's responsible
no because at the end of the day women
men have no say in abortion if you get a
girl pregnant and you're crying to her
and saying i don't want you to get that
abortion there ain't [ __ ] there ain't
[ __ ] you can do you can't save that kid
and
so at the end of the day a woman can't
have a child that they don't want to
have
so i fully agree with that i feel like
i'm fully like that's my person but like
if i ever got pregnant so i am sexually
active i'm not on contraception but i
tell men straight away i'm like come in
me don't come on me and i'm like but i
know if that if that happens i'm like
well it's my responsibility to be like
girl you're what what are you doing in
these streets
we're having
a host season
this season but i am i am that's why i
tell you oh my god
that's why you can get one std that
ruins your life i've already had
chlamydia i got chlamydia
i was 18 it was the second guy i ever
slept with my life we were friends we
went xyz and then i get that text being
like hey and i was like hey he's like oh
so um
i uh wear a condom uh no okay
but that is what i learned people don't
know he didn't he didn't come inside me
either
okay but that doesn't mean you're being
responsible
but a lot of people if you don't know
the media is passed just through contact
they don't need to come inside you so
even if they've got come in here on
their hand
what would reduce your odds i mean at
that point at that point i was a very
different human being but i'm like oh i
had come here but you're not because
you're doing the same thing now
well no no because i make sure that
everyone i make sure that everyone also
how do you make them get tested and make
them great really we don't say clean
either so i was an ex sexual health
professional we don't say clean we say
std free because obviously the opposite
of clean is dirty and we don't we don't
um perpetuate that like stigma so i'll
say like
i i literally will say to people and be
like hey i'll tell them i'm like i'm not
on contraception but i i get tested very
regularly wait wait you're not well
you're not on birth control
no no
and that is because
i can't
and that is because it [ __ ] it [ __ ]
up my hair [ __ ] up my body it [ __ ]
up everything you know what god [ __ ] up
your body a baby
but i'm responsible for that i'm
responsible for that what income no no
but what i'm saying is abortion but the
wrong thing is you know what else [ __ ]
up your body
abortion yeah and your mental health
this is what we're talking about it's
responsibility is that i'm like if that
happened so i tell men and they're like
oh pull out method or
i'm like okay like if you do you want to
use a condom like cool would like i'm
like yeah i'd rather they did but if i
ever got pregnant i wouldn't be like
well it's your fault i'd be like no this
is okay but this is like point in case
where women are using abortion as a form
of birth control instead of something
that should be used in an emergency oh
no no so like fortunately that's it i'm
27 i've like had a lot of i've had a lot
of girls also yeah um but that's it i'm
like yeah we will either i'll tell men
and so a lot of men a lot of men that i
sleep with
actually to be fair most of them are
like well i'm either not going to come
on you or i'm going to wear a condom or
i'm like you're just not going to finish
like okay okay we'll finish in a another
way um
and if a guy is like i'm still going to
try and finish beside you i'm like no
you're not because like i'll call you
daddy but i don't want to make you a
daddy like that's literally like
i will say that to men all the time
i just want to clarify some
understanding so right now you're in the
streets right yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
street you're streaming you know streets
but even that is that is a judgment on
women to be like hey casual sex is not
okay for women
i didn't say if it was okay for
you date them you date them and you're
not on birth control and you have them
finishing you no they don't finish me no
no no no no no no never never not come
on no no no the opposite the opposite oh
okay oh oh no no
[ __ ] there's like oh my
i was gonna correct her but i wanted to
see how far this would go oh god oh my
god no okay no no that's my bad that oh
no there's that here's the love here's
the honor if you can't come in here come
on her i tell men straight away straight
away i'm like do not finish inside me
and that's why i say
i'm like i will call you daddy do you
want to be a daddy they all go no people
let me just clarify you're only you
don't have the more condoms though your
only form of is pull out oh no no like
they could wear a condom but then then
it's on the guy that they're like well i
don't want to no no no no no you get to
pick so like like dude do you make them
wear a condom i don't make them if they
don't want to okay but then i i have the
conversation with them i'm like look
you've got choices either you don't
finish you wear a condom okay or you
pull out but i'm well aware that if they
don't if they don't pull out in time i'm
like i'm just trying to recycle too yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um i get tested very regularly that's it
x sexual health professional sexual
health is the one part of our health
that we are fully responsible for we are
fully responsible for getting tested we
are fully responsible for being here we
are fully responsible and i do think as
an individual as a woman if i was to get
pregnant from my reckless behavior i'd
be like it's not on you it's on me i
have taken that risk yeah and i was like
i'm taking that risk but because i am
very comfortable with the idea of i know
the walsh is not nice yeah i'm not here
like if i get pregnant i have an
abortion i'm like you know what if like
you don't get in a car thinking i'm
going to be in a car accident but you
know full well every time you get in a
car or you get on a plane
there is a low-key chance that this
could not end well for me it's just
interesting